[Musique]
je m'appelle rex et ma place n'est pas
dans une cage
je suis le corps dit la reine ah ouais
c'est le prince philip qui m'a offert à
sa majesté bon j'admets que je n'ai pas
toujours été un enfant facile j'ai
toujours été le sien préférés de la
reine
je suis tellement populaire que sa
majesté a fait mettre mon portrait sur
un mode d comme le téléphone à une
balayette pour toilettes
si tu es vraiment celui tu dis que tu es
commente intérêt ici j'ai fait une très
grosse bêtise c'est mort du président je
crois bien que ceux ci dessous diane
tell et je me suis enfui
je suis mort joe louis c'était mon
meilleur ami une fois que je serai le
nouveau loin il va y avoir du changement
dans la maison j'exige que vous
détourner le regard comme ceci charlie a
tout manigancé maintenant c'est lui qui
va devenir le numéro 1 des mois au
palais de buckingham
t'as aucune chance mon pote
[Musique]
oublie la manade et tyson je suis morte
à la meilleure équipe de coke te
souviens tu de ce vieux films rocky
sellout cider qui gagne à la fin
ok a perdu bernard même de rocky 2
[Musique]
dans l'autre comme le dit le proverbe
l'union fait la force ensemble nous
serons libres
[Musique]
bravo c'est partant alors mettons
discours était super
[Musique]